aujourd'hui la question que je pose le
seul média tous les personnes qui sont
par rapport à ce problème là comment se
fait-il qu laisse ouvertes et grandes
surfaces
vous croyez que les grandes surfaces
sont produits qu'à dit on rentre c'est
plus une seule - confie nick démarche en
plein air regardez la distance en
consommer tous moins de quasi de
personnes ici mon nom est personne et
nous on a besoin de travailler
on n'a pas de patron qui vous nous payez
derrière nous pour nous dire vous êtes
en en chômage technique ou des choses
comme ça donc je prends que des mesures
doivent être prises je suis d'accord
pour le maintien donc d'en gagner très
de la population mais à des réactions
qui sont des fois prises sans nous
demander notre accord soit notre demande
je pense que aussi on a besoin de faire
vivre tout le monde on apporte du bien
et nous on fait aussi des tournées dans
les petits villages on l'amène aussi un
lien social donc je pense que c'est très
important dans le temps en ce moment
qu'on entraîne de vivre d'avoir ce lien
social qui se perd de jour en jour